let's go to our next question today hey
David what do you think is the most
addictive legal substance in the world
besides tobacco right I would have said
tobacco I personally think that it might
be sugar I think that the most addictive
substance is love
now I'm kidding that's not really a
substance in the traditional sense I I
do think that that it's probably sugar I
have a hard time thinking of something
other than sugar that it would be and
increasingly we are learning more and
more about the brains response to sugar
in sort of normal brains right of course
you have people who have maybe
particular conditions that relate to
sugar which might change how the mind
responds to or craves or reacts to sugar
but I I would agree with that I think
it's sugar and I have a hard time
thinking of something that's even
similar and this is not like my opinion
I'm not even like a big sweets guy I
have two bites of cake and all of a
sudden I'm craving something savory so
this is not but don't don't mistake this
for some kind of personal vendetta of
any kind the studies I've been reading
increasingly linked or correlate the
brains responds to sugar when it becomes
accustomed to it to that of some pretty
serious drugs yeah what are the other
candidates we could consider right now
alcohol caffeine caffeine and is sugar
even considered a drug I mean maybe it
has they said subsets not drug okay if
that's yep I think sugar is pretty
addictive caffeine is an interesting one
though let me think about that so I know
that if you this wouldn't be me of
course I don't do this but I know that
there are people who have many cups of
coffee a day and as soon as they don't
they get a headache right that's that's
a very specific response but you can
take a couple advil or just have one cup
of coffee sometimes depending on how bad
your your body is craving the caffeine
and that headache will go away is that
caffeine addiction or dependency greater
or not as significant as sugar I don't
actually know the answer I mean maybe
caffeine is as as as addictive as sure
yeah like what would be the sugar
withdrawals maybe you're groggy for a
little while you don't have the energy
that you're used to sleep all day
I don't know I actually think that maybe
there is a case to be made that caffeine
is in some sense
more addictive than sugar on a
day-to-day basis but it's I mean not
that many people do sugar fats right
yeah I mean it's tough in a sense
because you can't get completely off of
sugar right
it is carbohydrates and we need that
after all to sustain our existence sure
and I see to minimize it but you can't
get completely off of it do we
distinguish between refined sugars and
and naturally occurring sugars in
talking about this I think we do right
maybe we should I think we should can't
make the case that you gotta get off the
fruit right don't want my apples my
oranges I love friend bananas and
cherries who's gonna turn down a banana
and cherry yeah I am gonna go with sugar
I am going with sugar and I think that
that is based on the data that we've
seen I think a legal substance that we
have become hugely dependent on and it
is actually reacting in the brain the
way some pretty serious drugs do if you
think it's something other than sugar or
caffeine that's legal remember I want to
hear from you right in david pakman.com
slash contact what could it be sugar or
caffeine what else might people write in
about not to do some follow up yeah I'm
gonna vegan cheese that I mean that's
stuff oh yeah that stuff is like crack I
mean come on that's there nobody could
resist that and it's actually not legal
that they're actually making the vegan
cheese is so addictive that they're
making it illegal in some southern
states because they're just very tough
on that and that's our top story on
Monday on the bunt on the bonus show we
will be discussing that yeah all right
send me your thoughts what could be more
addictive legal substance than caffeine
or sugar we've got a great bonus show
for you today
subscribe get access to it at WWE at
muncom or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show